quand tu es devenu flic 3 mai du bac
c'est ça que tu voulais faire quand tu
étais petit
non je l'aide patineuse et comme on est
passé du patin au flingue
je sais pas ça s'est fait comme ça
allez bonne journée je te crois pas
et vous crise en grèce moi je pense pas
comme s'il y avait un désert dans ma
tête j'ai pas de messie comme personne
cherche à bari stick entendant souffler
et j'avance l'odeur de mort on a beau se
savonner s'est par contre quand je
rentre le soir et des sap estime jusqu'à
60 message c'est pas rentrer toute cette
merde chez moi un gars doit être
présenté à la viande en trois heures
c'est nous qui faisons la reconduit de
31 points mais c'est pas notre boulot
pourquoi ça nous faire ça c'est le type
avec le pull orange méfiez vous quand
même
éventuelles pourquoi une décision
d'expulsion a été prise si on était
certain qu'il allait se faire buter à
son retour
eddie puise exagère les menaces pour
avoir leur statut de réfugiés comme on
fait la différence entre un réfugié un
terroriste
rien à voir également chez moi le [ __ ]
c'est ça j'ai obéi aux ordres
c'est mon boulot figurez-vous juste un
pauvre
pas de couilles au cul en faites pas les
tiennent tous vents
velshi personnes intéressement je serai
preuve du contraire
vingt ans de service pas une tache au
dossier il a fallu vous foutu la merde
[Musique]